نبدا بسائل العقوبات ضد ايران اليوم فبعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا اعلنت وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات جديده على
ايران واوضحت الخزانه الامريكيه في بيانا
العقوبات الجديده على ايران تستهدف 10
افراد والمؤسسه التعاونيه التابعه للحرس
الثوري واضاف البيان ان العقوبات تشمل
نائب وزير المخابرات الايراني واربعه من
قاده الحرس الثوري الايراني هذا واكدت
الخزانه الامريكيه ان العقوبات استهدفت
مسؤولين عن القمع في ايران والجهات التي
تمولهم مشيره الى ان النظام الايرانيه
يعتمد على المحاكمات الصوريه والاعدامات
لقمع الشعب
للحديث عن العقوبات الامريكيه التي صدرت
قبل قليل ينظم الينا من واشنطن بير غانم
مراسل العربيه في تفاصيل هذه العقوبات
وكيف ستنعكس قانونيا وسياسيا على ايران
صادر عن وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ان هذه
العقوبات تاتي بالتنسيق مع الاوروبيين
والاتحاد الاوروبي هذا امر اول الامر
الثاني هو يؤكد ايضا ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ملتزمه بحقوق الانسان في ايران
ومعاقبه الاطراف ان كان واشخاص او جهاد من
من يقنعون هذه الحقوق في ايران يشير بيان
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه الى انه استهدف
كما ذكرت انت قبل قليل التعاونيه التابعه
للحرس الثوري الايراني والمقصود بذلك هو
محاوله مواجهه عمليات التمويل التي تصل
الى الحرس الثوري الايراني بالاضافه الى
ذلك هناك عقبه على ضباط كبار من الحرس
الثوري الايراني الذين يعملون في بعض
المقاطعات الغربيه مثل الاصفهان وغيرها
واا يقول ايضا بعد التفاصيل المهمه في هذا
البيان الى ولاقى الاشخاص ينتمون الى ما
يعتبر في الحرس الثوري الايراني قياده
النجف وهي طبعا موجوده في العراق وليست
موجوده في ايران وهذه اشاره واضحه الى ما
يقوم به الحرس الثوري على الاراضي
الايرانيه وطموحاته خارج الاراضي
الايرانيه وبالتالي نحن امام حزمه ضغط
جديده من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
والامريكيين على ايران وطهران هل هناك
يعني همم توقع
ات داخل واشنطن حول رد الفعل ايراني الذي
بدا المسؤولين بالالماح اليه عبر استهداف
المصالح الاوروبيه
وتاليا المصالح الغربيه في الشرق الاوسط
وفي بعض المناطق الاخرى
بعيدا عن العقوبات القطاعيه الكبيره مثل
العقوبات على النفط او على القطاع المصرفي
الايراني والمصرف المركزي الايراني هذه
العقوبات تعبر اكثر عن محاوله اعلان موقف
مبدئي من قبل الدول
الغربيه خصوصا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ربما تزعج في بعض الاحيان المحاولات
الايرانيه في تمويل الحرس الثوري الايراني
لكنها لا تذهب ابعد من ذلك وكذلك
التهديدات الايرانيه الغربيين والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تذهب اكثر من كونها
كلام في كلام
شكرا لك على المراس العربيه حدثنا واشنطن
قبل ان عقوبات الامريكيه اعلنت الحكومه
البريطانيه فرض عقوبات جديده ايضا استهدفت
مسؤولين وكيانات ايرانيه لدورهم في
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في البلاد واوضحت
لندن ان العقوبات شملت تجميد اصول قائد
القوات البريه في الجيش الايراني ونائب
القائد العام للحرس الثوري ونائب قائد
ميليشيا البسيج وحظرهم من السفر كما قررت
الحكومه البريطانيه تجميد اصول البسيج
مؤكده ان العقوبات تعكس ادانه العنف الذي
يمارسه النظام بحق شعبان بما في ذلك اعدام
لبريطاني الايرانيه على رضا اكبر بدوره
قال وزير الخارجيه لبريطانيه ان بلاده
فرضت 50 عقوبه شديده مرتبطه بنتهاكات حقوق
الانسان في ايران منذ مقتل مع سامي
مع استمرار النظام في قمع تظاهرات
الاحتجاجيه اعلى من الاتحاد الاوروبي
للموافقه على فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده ضد
ايران مشيرا الى ان الحزمه الجديده تستهدف
قاده ايرانيين متهمين باستخدام القمع ضد
المتظاهرين هذا وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي
رفضه لاستخدام القوه بشكل وحشيه من قبل
السلطات الايرانيه ضد المتظاهرين السلميه
في الاثناء مشاهدينا اعلن وزير خارجيات
النمسا عن ادراج 37 شخصا وكيانا جديدا على
قائمه عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي مشيرا الى
ان هذه الاجراءات ستستمر بسبب تورط ايران
في جرائم حرب بشكل غير مباشره
37 شخصا وكيانا جديدا على قائمه عقوبه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وستستمر هذه الاجراءات
علينا مواصله الضغط طالما ان ايران تشارك
بشكل غير مباشر في جرائم الحرب وترسل
طائره بدون طيار وربما صواريخ الى روسيا
للحديث اكثر عن هذه العقوبات معنا من
بريكسال لمراس العربيه نوردين فريدي نور
الدين يعني امام حملت الضغط الاوروبيه
الامريكيه المنفقه على نظام الايراني هناك
عواقب قانونيه وسياسيه بعد هذه العقوبات
فتطالى النظام الايراني الذي حذر من من
خطورتها على العلاقه بين الطرفين تفاصيل
لهذه العقوبات والاجواء السياسيه
من جنايات الحرس الثوري الايراني زائد عدد
من المحافظين ومسؤولين في هيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون وهيئات الاتصال وشركات
التكنولوجيا اضافه الى عدد من
الكائنات اغلب الكائنات في هذه القائمه
تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني ولكن بحجله
على سبيل المثالي يعني همم القائمه تضم
كادم احمد رئيس كربلاء في الحرس الثوري
الايراني احمد عظمي رئيس قسم النجف الاشرف
في الحرس الثوري الايراني وليس في العراق
يعني في ايران
عباس مرتضى نائب قائد الحارس الثوري
الايراني
مسلم معين رئيس مقر البشيش في الامن
السيبراني قائد الحرس الثوري في محافظه
بلوشستان محمد كرامي رئيس جهاز النظام
العام في محافظه كرمشه والكيانات منها
كائنات القدس فيلق القدس وقوات الحارس
الثوري في محافظه كرمنشاه الى غير ذلك
المهم ايضا في ان هذه العقوبات هذه الحزمه
تستهدف طبعا جزء من الحرس الثوري وبعد
القيادات تاتي تكمل ثلاث حزومات
اتخذت في شهر اكتوبر ونوفمبر وادي ديسمبر
تؤكد كل جميع هذه الازمات ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي مستمر ايضا في اتجاه التصعيد
تصعيد الضغط على ايران في موازاته همم
مواصلاتها هذا القمع والضغط يهدي هناك الى
ان تخفف السلطات الايرانيه ما قبلتها وهذا
القمع شديد ضد الشعب الايراني لذلك قال
على سبيل المثال شعر رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
ان هذه الحزمه هي رساله واضحه في اتجاه في
اتجاه ايران في اتجاه نظام من اجل ان يوقف
شعبه وان الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يقف مكتوف
الايدي امام سياست ايران هذا ما يتعلق
بالجزء الخاص في هذه العقوبات والتي لن
تكون الاخيره
ونستخدم هنا لن يعني حسبه العقوبات
الرابعه لم تكون الاخيره اذا وصلت ايران
هذا شان ننقل ذلك عن دبلوماسينا اوروبيين
يتعاملون مع الملف الايراني بشكل منتظم
لكن طبعا تختلف عن ما ينتظره او عن
المقاربه الامريكيه معلومه من المقاربه
الامريكيه وضعت في فتره ما الحارس الثوري
ككل في قائمه العقوبات الامريكيه لكن
الاوروبيون يفضلون منهجيه التدرس وادراج
المسؤولين كمسؤولين والكيارات
حتى اكثر فاكثر فنجد العشرات من المسؤولين
في الحرس الثوري الايراني في مختلف في
قوائم العقوبات من العواق بدعم روسيا في
العسكريه بتعلق سوريا
الايراني وعلى البرنامج صواريخ البالستيه
وبالتالي المدرجون منذ 2010 حسب ما قالت
وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه اليوم وكل هذا لا لا يعني ان لا
لا يقفل المشاورات المشاورات تظل مفتوحه
بين الدبلوماسيين حول ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني بموجب نظام اخر الوزير لم تتحدث
مثلا كاترين كل العالم تتحدث عن قائمه
الارهاب او قائمه همم انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان قالت نبحث امكانيه ادراجه بموجب
بنظام ماء او نظام اخر فهناك المشاورات
متواصله الملاحظه الثالثه بسرعه هذه
المشاورات طبعا مقيده
بالقانون الاوروبي الذي يشترته وجود حكم
قضائي مستقل في دوله الاتحاد شكرا